hello friends we are back its e3 2015
day one annum with Matt who's been to
see uncharted 4 mm oh hey so proud so
you went to see a demonstration of
uncharged for did you actually it to
play the game I know it was a basically
just lie like a gameplay demonstration I
was Sean right yeah so basically a video
of what went down I got to see the same
thing however i think the trailer the we
saw was a little bit longer than the
trailer they showed yesterday the sony's
e3 press conf they ended it by a good
like 45 minutes 6 minutes right so
extended by about five minutes and that
does sound slightly insignificant but
actually I imagine there's quite a lot
to that right so what did you see in
that extra five minutes what was going
on well what people saw last night was a
you know Drake basically using the
grappling hook on that moving truck and
it just a scaffold and it just cuts off
yeah cut thats where it cuts off for the
press conference right so what happens
after that uh well he can there the
chase basically continues he gets
dragged into like the mud yeah basically
gets dragged and gets beat the crap out
of so he's on the back of the Jeep and
he's being dragged along the mud right
yeah if I remember correctly people who
didn't start shooting at him about at
that point right yeah yeah the typical
stuff for drill all the time all day all
day at the office not a problem for him
know so he crashes everything messes up
right this is how I remember at least so
that Jeep crashes he's then underneath
the Jeep and then he's knocked out right
is that what happens yeah yeah the Jeep
basically crashes in he's just like
knocked out and then like it starts
lighting on fire and he wakes up a bit
yeah it's the beautiful face sort of
emerges from its stupor as the fire is
surrounding him so but he's caught
inside the Jeep and it starts going on
fire right right and then you basically
do like a quick time event to kind of
get out of there yeah that's right yeah
and what happens after that I don't
actually remember is I could such a
terrible well he basically inches his
way out and then he pushes out do it the
door and then were a bunch of people to
start shooting at them right off the bat
right so I mean you didn't get a chance
to play it do you think that's it do you
think that's a bad sign right now I mean
it I guess is not
far away from from relief i actually did
again i guess they're giving it 2016
release window i guess there are some
months to go what do you think about the
fact you weren't able to play I mean I'm
totally fine with it it all still looks
and runs pretty solidly from what I'm
seeing and to be honest it's a lot of
what we've seen from the inserted series
in the past and I think these set pieces
in odd stuff it we've seen it happen and
I could imagine it running just as well
when we get our hands on when he comes
out right I see okay I personally when I
was watching the extended trailer I had
a couple of reservations I think the
main one that I had is that everything
there's just so much to it now there's
so much razzamatazz to it there's so
much they're just throwing everything
into it and a good friend of mine once
told me that if you put everything in
bold then you put nothing in bold so
everything is crazy all the time then
nothing is crazy all the time and I was
watching all this mad [ __ ] happening all
around me and I was like pretty normal
because I wasn't thrilled where does
that make sense where am I just a
horrible boring sin it I mean it's
totally understandable running it it's
just lots of stuff happening as always
in sort of when you play and charted in
and it starts to kind of dull the effect
over time as ya get it it's like a
diminishing return right you can only
see an explosion so many times to pull
you like okay yeah he's he survived
again that's fine ray right well for
more news analysis and features on
uncharted 4 stay tuned to gamespot com
you